hello i'm zaiha and i'm a fourth year
medical student studying in the uk if
you're a bilingual person who's looking
for a job with no experience hopefully
you can learn from this and apply for
the companies i'll be recommending and
start earning money these are the points
we'll go through so let's go for it i
earn between two thousand and seven
hundred to three thousand pounds a month
this depends on how many hours i work
this is through working as an over the
phone interpreter for a translation
service agency most of my clients around
80 of them are healthcare professionals
such as doctors nurses midwives
caregivers and the ambulance rest of the
20 of my clients are from metropolitan
police in london uk or from fbi in the
us and also sometimes i get calls from
bank and from gas and electric companies
in summary my clients and the nature of
the calls i translate for can vary a lot
you translate a specific language like
spanish mandarin hindi whichever
language yourself and the customer can
speak to english then you translate from
english back to that language i thought
the best way to explain how over the
phone translation works is to show you
guys an example of it so i hope you guys
appreciate my terrific acting skills
hello this is zeliha interpreter id 0-0
for turkish this call may be monitored
for training and quality assurance
purposes is your customer with you or
would you like me to call them for you
hello interpreter i'm a doctor working
in a gp surgery and i'm here with my
patient who's a baby and his dad could
you please ask the dad what's the
problem and how can we help him today
my son has been having diarrhea for the
last three days alright could you tell
me a bit more about this diarrhea
i genuinely enjoy this job because you
get to witness the most real moments of
the lives of strangers you hear about
their life stories and it helps you
appreciate the difficult and different
lives that other people live and i feel
humbled to be able to help them on top
of that i earn money when i'm in my
pajamas and from the comfort of my own
home also if you'd like to see a vlog of
how i earn money and spend my day as a
freelance interpreter you can see that
on my channel as well and i'll put the
link here
this is a common question that i get
asked by family and friends when i tell
them i work as a freelance interpreter i
get paid for every second that i'm on
the call for so if i don't receive calls
then i don't get paid but most of the
time that i'm logged into the
interpreter portal i do receive calls
because i get calls from both the us and
the uk clients so if it's night time for
the uk and there is no translation
services to do for them then there is
always calls coming from the u.s because
for them it would be daytime and they
would be in need of translation services
mostly between 8am to 6pm i get calls
from the uk and after 6pm i usually get
calls from the us this is the online
interpreter portal so here each one of
these are calls that i have received
that day and the duration of those calls
are shown in seconds for example this
call lasted for six thousand and seven
hundred and three seconds which would
make almost two hours how much i get
paid is calculated by adding up all
these seconds if you receive a call you
don't have to be actively translating in
that call to get paid for example if a
doctor is examining a patient or taking
gloves from them and there is nothing to
translate during that time but i still
get paid for the time that i wait for
them to finish what they're doing or
when a banker puts me on hold to write
down some notes on his computer then i
get paid for that as well basically
every second that i'm on the call for i
get paid doesn't matter if i'm actively
translating or not
there are so many over the phone
translation companies because after
covert hit as you know everything moved
from face to face to over the phone and
it stayed that way even after most of
the covered restrictions have been
removed and thankfully finally companies
started caring more about inclusivity
and equal opportunities of people with
cultural and language barriers but these
are the top three companies i'd suggest
you to apply with no experience in
translating first company that i would
recommend especially if you have no
experience at all is language line
solutions i personally work for them and
this is the third biggest language
service provider in the world and when i
first applied i had no experience in
translation at all other than the
unofficial translations that i've been
doing for my family and friends i get
paid 14 pounds and 40 pence per hour and
i've been working under them for the
last two years also i'll put the links
of these companies in the description
box of this video so if you want to see
that you can check that out second
company that you can apply for is
language empire this is a company that
does face-to-face translation services
so it's not over the phone but this
company is the easiest one to get into
in my opinion because both myself and my
friend who had no experience in
translating at all applied to this place
and got the job offer so it's definitely
worth a try as this company does
face-to-face translations you need to
travel to the place that your
translation service is required but the
travel costs are paid for the hourly
rate for this is 14 pounds so 40 pence
lower than the previous company also
when i researched them the employee
reviews and employee satisfaction
weren't great but i'm not sure how
accurate this is because even though i
got the job offer i've never actually
worked for them as i prefer working from
home third company is transperfect this
is the biggest language service provider
in the world professional proficiency in
over the phone consecutive
interpretation is required
so i assume they're not as big in a
friendly as the first company which was
language line because on the language
lines website disqualification is only
preferred not required according to
glassdoor this company also pays 1440 to
their employees
there are three stages in the
application process that you'll be
required to pass to get the job offer
first one is an obvious one uploading
your cv second one is interview and the
third one short translation test for the
first stage which is uploading your cv
my top tip would be to look at the
skills they're looking for in the job
description and add those to your cv to
prove that you have those skills and
relate those at least one of your past
experiences this doesn't have to be a
job experience it can be an experience
you acquired from your university or
from your school i took a module called
fundamental skills for scientists and in
that module we had to send a cv for a
specific job that they assigned us and i
scored 100 out of 100 in that assignment
and the tip that i've just given you
probably helps me a lot to get that full
mark second stage is the interview my
top tip for this would be definitely
just proving them that you know about
the importance of confidentiality of
your customers and of your clients and
that you're confident you won't let any
confidentiality breach to happen because
of a mistake that you do because in the
calls that you'll be translating
personal and financial information will
be discussed so you need to show them
that you know how to protect that
information and how to get rid of that
information safely for example by
practicing clean desk policy and by not
speaking about the conversations you
translated to anyone because
confidentiality breaches cost millions
of dollars to these companies and to
refresh your knowledge on
confidentiality you need to complete a
yearly compliance training on their
learning portal third stage is the short
translation test if you've come to this
stage well done this is the easy stage
to pass in my opinion because here they
only test if you actually speak the
language that you claimed you do before
this test they send you a list of around
300 key terms that could come up during
your assessment these are mostly medical
and financial terms so my top tip would
be for you to familiarize yourself with
those terms so that's basically it i
hope this was useful consider
subscribing and i'll see in the next one
my patience
[Laughter]
okay
okay baby
it's done
[Music]